I'm two years post mastectomy, ER-positive cancer, and three years post
hysterectomy for fibrate, so totally different, not cancer. Taking IP-6 to
Merrill clear, which is a tumeric, astro clear, astro dim, which is a dim product to
decrease astrogensal porosine, which is a broccoli product, and to decrease that
astrogensal spectrosol C, which is a binder, and it can grab on to circulating
tumor cells. Do we copy it as daily? Great for stimulating the person to the
X, doing the right nightly, left toxic job. Interesting comment there, this person
is recognizing that emotions play such a part in a person's health. You're under a
very stressful situation, whether it's a relationship or a job environment, what
does that do? It cooks you in a sympathetic, overdrive. Your parasympathetics go into
the toilet, and you need a parasympathetic stimulation, or under the
stimulated immune response, in order to stimulate detoxification pathways.
So you're in this hyper-sympathetic situation because of the environment to
relationships that you're in, it can be very difficult. Overall feeling well, but
I've recently started having hot flashes. Okay, so why does a person have hot flashes?
So women have hot flashes when they have, when they're
go through their change of life, their goits are menopause, and they're having a decrease
in production of estrogen and progesterone by their ovaries. So while your ovaries start
to shut down, you could have hot flashes. Why don't? Why doesn't every woman have hot flashes?
I know somebody who they went through menopause, and it was just fine. They never had any symptoms
whatsoever. The reason is, is that if you have really healthy adrenals, your adrenals also produce
subestrogen. So the person that goes through menopause, it has no side effects, no hot flashes,
is a person who had very healthy adrenals. So that while their ovaries were shutting down,
their adrenals were giving them just enough estrogen to keep them from heavy hot flashes.
Now, the issue is, persons ER positive, and they're taking things to decrease estrogen.
That alone can cause hot flashes. So if you have an ER positive, we would know your two-years
post-bestectomy, and you got a clean bill of health, you don't want to be adding things. So let's
say in person, did not have cancer, no history of cancer, they had hot flashes. I would recommend
a product with different herbs in it, like black cohalsh and macaroon that could help balance
your estrogens and products that may be soy-derived estrogen precursors. That could really help
balance a person's estrogens to decrease their hot flashes during that change of life. But if
you're ER positive, history of ER positive cancer, you really can't do that. So then what would I do?
I would use adaptogens. So as person goes on, they explain other symptoms that they're having
in a pausal symptoms. What would I do? That's a safe thing is use adaptogens. So
and you know that we have the we have the adaptoclear. That's a good one. We also have the
primary research lab. I think it's called adaptogens R3. We have several from
four to molecular, but they're not on the website. So it's ortho-black. It doesn't let us put
stuff on the website anywhere. So you'd have a call in for that. The one I like best from them is the new adapt.
And then there are, then we have also our cortoclear, which is a good adaptogens to. So there's multiple
adaptogens to choose from. Well what should I do? If it was me, I would start with the adaptoclear.
Start by taking three a day. That can help. You don't want to do things to help stimulate estrogen
to get a positive cancer. That's the problem. That would be the easiest way to get rid of your
you could be taking some estrogen precursors and you literally could basically shut down all your
hot flashes and such. But that could be bad for the cancer. So you wouldn't want to do that.